so i think without any further ado
we start the game uh i wish i'd studied
his uh
his openings um
but i think we're just gonna figure out
on the fly
what openings he plays yeah virgo sin
so my opponent is says narayanan from
india
he's very very strong um
he got to the semifinals of the banter
blitzcap the last time
and where he was pretty close to
to beating firozia
who beat me in the final so that tells
you
everything about the kind of player that
he is
yeah i don't know why i'm playing this
line uh exactly but
there we go okay
basically black has the bishop pair uh
and um
for that i may have a
slightly better center and uh possibly
the knight and c6 could be a bit
misplaced
but i think in reality it is much
uh yeah don't know what to do here
let's go a3
maybe there is some kind of bishop c3
rook c3 e5 now
could potentially
once again i have very little clue about
what i'm doing
but it's fine it's it's the first game
and it there seems to be
sort of a hard hard limit to how bad
this can be
like clearly clearly it's not great but
i don't think
it's it's going ever going to be that
bad
uh yeah so bishop f8 i'm i think
reasonably happy to see again i was more
worried about bishop c3 followed by by
e5
um yeah i guess i just continued with
bishop b2
he would love to go dc4 queen c4
um and then e5 to free his position but
then i think
d5 comes and see
c7 is hanging so so that's that's a
major
major issue for um for him
and if you kind of freeze position
fairly soon then i will perhaps have a
slight advantage with um
with my my extra space and um and
the knight on c6 blocking the c pawn
compensating for the fact that he does
have the three bishops
i'm expecting probably rook v8 now yeah
that's what it did i think i'll just
continue to
develop normally bishop d7 i think can
never
be that great because cd5 comes and
i don't think he can exploit the x-ray
of the bishop versus the queen so
finally decides to give up the center
but um
now i am as
as they say i am clearly slightly better
so i think we we just
um do this bring the knight to better
square
if he does capture in c5 i'm going to
take back with the queen obviously
exchange exchange those and
still the pressure on c7 will be
will be a major issue for him now i
think bishop d3 is quite good
then bishop b4 um possibly increasing
the pressure
yeah queen d5 queen c2
bishop b4 is coming next he probably
would like to go 97 and
to play um
to play um to play c6 but
knight g7 bishop e4 loses loses b7 after
he moves the queen
otherwise there's bishop c5 and i have
to decide whether to give a check on h7
uh and then go back to e4 whether i just
want to go to e4 immediately
thing is if i go [ __ ] page seven
probably i'm just provoking king f8
and obviously then i can
decide not to exchange queens but i
still think i want to exchange queens so
i'm just gonna going to win
one tempo with um which b4 i don't think
he has any tactics if queen a2
there's rook a1 trapping the queen
um and otherwise i'm just uh
i'm just taking back on c5 with um
with a somewhat better position and
clearly the bishop is well placed on on
e sat
on e4 pressuring uh pressuring c
uh sorry b7 and also the knight in c6
so that's i think a pretty clean tempo
that i win
um yeah let me go h4
get some luft for the for
the the king uh
also in the ending i could at some
moment be aiming for
uh be aiming for um let me see i think
i'm just gonna go wish me one
i could take on c6 and then go knight e5
but then
his bishop would be quite reasonable and
i think i would be selling my advantage
a little bit too short
so he goes for a very reasonable plan
here exchanging his bishops but
bishop but i think he still has
major major issues to solve here
[Music]
yeah king h8 he would have probably
liked to move the queen away
in order not to um
[Music]
yeah in order to possibly exploit my my
slightly weakened king but
then the f5 pawn was hanging because of
the pen
um
you know what i think i'm just gonna
force the game a little bit here
oh not not d5 then it takes and there's
a pin
so i take and then i go d5 but then
there is rook d8 again
that is more than a little unfortunate
okay
g6 not for sure about g6 because i get
time for rook c1
bishop b3 looks very very strong
no defense against bishop a4
see i think i'm i'm just more or less
winning here there was also bishop takes
e6 there followed by d5 but this
seems seems sorry cleaner
um yeah i don't even have to take though
i can go b4 should speed up at some
point
you know the old
stop talking start playing trick
okay that is a good defense didn't
really
didn't really write that okay i'm gonna
go for mate
g6 is the only only chance
clearly do i have mate probably not
but i do have this
f4 wow he's fighting so well
fighting annoyingly well
i didn't finish that one
i don't know i just collapsed i missed
it i started to miss everything
i'm still much better but
yeah this this really shows you why he
was doing well in the last
the last banter blitz cup because he
clearly
fights extremely well
i should be i should be able to convert
this i think he
he messed it up a bit again
okay two clean pumps up it's a little
bit more difficult with two rooks on the
board than just the one but
it still should still be easy and he uh
he resigned so i guess that's
um that's it